[Musique]
stockholm friday's 'future' mouvement
des écoliers pour le climat devenu
planétaire est né ici dans la capitale
suédoise
de même le greta timber son égérie n'est
pas de la manifestation ou plutôt oui
mais sur écran géant en direct de new
york où elle s'apprête à assister à la
session extraordinaire de l'onu sur le
climat en 13 mois à peine cette lycéenne
de 16 ans est devenue la suédoise la
plus connue au monde ses soeurs jumelles
à peine plus âgé que greta ont rejoint
le mouvement presque dès ses débuts
nous les rencontrons à l'endroit même
devant le parlement ou greta tune berg a
commencé en solitaire à faire la grève
pour le climat à think that she's mezine
personnes je crois que c'est une
personne extraordinaire et nous avons
besoin d'une figure de proue pour que
les gens sachent qu'ils nous sommes dit
isabelle en même temps on sent une sorte
d'agacement devant les questions des
journalistes qui n'ont d'yeux que pour
greta dans la société suédoise très
égalitaire on n'aime pas trop les têtes
qui dépassent à willencourt nos leaders
je ne dirais pas qu'elle est une leader
dit sophia elle serait plutôt un symbole
du mouvement mais certainement pas son
leader car elle ne décide pas pour nous
qui est véritablement greta thun bern
élevé par une mère célèbre chanteuse
d'opéra et un père acteur avec une
petite soeur atteinte comme elle de
syndrome d'asperger r elle souffre
également de troubles obsessionnels
compulsifs
cette journaliste du quotidien expressen
qui a nommé greta femme de l'année l'a
rencontré la jeune militante lui a
confié qu être atteinte d'aspères guère
donner des super pouvoirs de
concentration vôtre
elle m'a dit aussi qu'à l'école c'était
difficile parce qu'elles étaient
différentes dit-elle les élèves
n'étaient pas tous gentils elle pleurait
tous les soirs à la maison et à l'école
elle se cacher dans les toilettes
elle se sentait différentes les choses
changent radicalement quand greta
commence sa grève pour le climat dans
cette école privée à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de la capitale qu'elle a
fréquenté l'an dernier elle rencontre
gabriela animatrice de sa propre chaîne
youtube
elles deviennent amis de gabriella fait
son tout premier podcast avec greta qui
est une inspiration dit elle children
joe stork chez take action parce qu'elle
ne fait pas que parler
elle agit s'exclame la jeune animatrice
elle s'est assise seule devant le
parlement
elle est totalement fidèle à elle même
dans tout ce qu'elle dit est ce qu'elle
fait ce journaliste spécialisé en
environnement qui a rencontré greta à
quelques reprises avoue avoir pleuré la
première fois qu'il l'a entendu devant
un parterre de politiciens de haut rang
et il n'était pas seul
elle avait l'air si fragile si petit qu
on a tous été jeunes et idéaliste et dit
il et on voulait changer le monde mais
nos professeurs nos parents ne nous
écoutait pas selon lui elle est une
véritable génie de la communication peu
brusque chute et la façon dont elle le
dit cette voix douce mais son message
aux politiciens toujours aussi brutales
greta tunes back n'a pas fini de
fasciner les suédois grâce à elle le
climat est devenu le sujet numéro un
dans les préoccupations de ses
compatriotes et un journal comme
expressen qui l'a nommé femme de l'année
consacre maintenant deux pages
quotidiennement au climat et offre à ses
400 journalistes des formations
hebdomadaire sur le réchauffement
climatique
et puis beaucoup de jeunes ici souhaite
que grille et a comme on dit en suédois
devienne la plus
récipiendaire du prix qui porte le nom
d'un autre célèbre suédois le prix nobel
de la paix ici alexandre achat de ce cap
radio canada stockholm